[Music]
donald trump's second impeachment trial
started this week and it began with a
48-minute opening statement
from trump's attorney
i don't want to talk about this who
cares trump isn't the president anymore
and we shouldn't have to keep
thinking about him i feel like he's
going to be popping up in the news
forever and ever
until either he dies or we do it's so
frustrating
i wish he had never been born
wait what's that noise hello amber
what the who are you i'm your guardian
angel here to show you the true nature
of your wishes in fact
i believe you just made a very
interesting one about trump
yeah i wish he had never been born
oh i understand that wish all too well
he's made our lives difficult for the
last few years
but there's always a dark side to every
wish in fact let me show you how
different your life would be
if donald trump had truly never been
born let's go
go where are we going
whoa where are we we're at 30 rock
above your studio don't you recognize it
wow
i guess i mean there's my desk and
there's tarik's podium but
it feels different that's because this
is what your show would be like in a
world where donald trump was never born
oh no trump never being born ruined my
show
i take it back i take it all back i
don't want any of this any
oh no i can't watch this see you from 30
rockefeller plaza in new york city
it's amber upton wait we have a full
audience
covered must be gone in this timeline
yes but that doesn't mean
everything's better here hey welcome to
the very special
3000th episode spectacular of the amber
ruffin show
we're very excited to have you here so
excited in fact that every single person
in our audience is going home with three
thousand dollars
just a fun little idea i took from my
good friend oprah
oh there she is now come give me a hug
girl
okay so in this universe there's no
pandemic we've already done 3 000
episodes and i'm friends with oprah
where's the bad part what just wait a
minute wishes always have an
unpredictable downside i'm sure
is coming soon
amber i have the most amazing news my
wife just gave birth to a beautiful baby
boy
i'm a father
that was trump connected to that at all
i don't know but so far
this timeline seems great you mind if i
put on this red baseball cap to
celebrate
sure seeing a red hat means absolutely
nothing to me
good point why would it
whoa we've got a really great show for
you tonight everybody
prince is here whoa whoa whoa prince is
still alive here
did prince die because of donald trump
no
i mean i can't prove it but that doesn't
make sense
there's got to be something in this
timeline that shows why your wish was
bad
now even though it's a happy day i do
want to take a moment
and acknowledge the terrible attack that
occurred at the capitol building
now there we go i mean i'm not trying to
cheer for a tragedy
but i was beginning to think this whole
timeline i'm talking of course about the
sneeze attack that overcame a young
senator
when a baby panda was brought into the
building for international cute things
day
so awful and i think we went 15 years
without any sickness in the entire
country
good thing we got rid of the two-party
system and legalized universal health
care or that senator would be in trouble
god bless president zendaya all right
this was a mistake
let's go home oh
man we're back in my own timeline that's
right
so what did you learn nothing absolutely
nothing
yeah this whole thing backfired i i
honestly might go live in that other
timeline myself
oh uh don't tell people about the prince
[Music]
thing
[Music]
you